Isto vai explodir a qualquer
momento teste de som teste de
som novas câmaras novo cenário Carlão
aquele é o Carlão e hoje vamos abrir
duas caixas misteriosas da Timo a caixa
dos Pobres a caixa barata e a caixa cara
esta caixa Foi cerca de 20 € e esta
caixa Foi cerca de 170 já sabem se
quiserem usar o meu link da team para
terem descontos dinheiro ofertas tá aí
embaixo vamos lá caixa barata como é que
eu vou abrir isto com a minha
unha Isto são matracas o mais conhecido
por nun
chacos espa aí
Ah olha a câmara embassou com o calor ai
meu Deus eu não posso treinar aqui e
grande mer eu consegui embassar a câmara
com as minhas artes marciais incrível
bom próximo produto temos aqui mais um
produto barato my shs não sei o que isto
é Isto é literalmente um checklist de
tarefas domésticas ou outras coisas
vocês metem aqui aquilo que querem fazer
durante o dia Escobar os dentes passear
o cão oito copos de água por dia olha
até gostei é barato mas é bem útil O que
é que tem aqui mais cenouras deve ser
daquelas coisas que vocês prendem os
restos de batata frita que tem sabem o
pacote Imaginem tem assim o vosso pacote
né cementes de sésame e tal ó pegam
nesta cenoura toma e já trancam olha
funciona super aprovado é barato e
funcional próxima coisa uma
joaninha Hum tenho quase a certeza que
isto é para a casa de banho é para
colocar a escova de dentes a câmara está
a embassar outra vez Porquê tá muito
calor aqui dentro é isso produção
hum Alguém sabe o que isto é eu não
tenho coragem sequer de colocar isto nos
dentes mano
ei Isto é aquele gel maluco pois isto é
feito em laboratório mesmo para estragar
os dentes né olha isto eu não tenho
coragem sequer tem assim um plastico
zinho com um químico esquece Vou mandar
fora já bom próximo produto que que é
isto isto foi assim não pode ah bom
próximo
produto Ok TIM OK eu acho que o próximo
produto é este A caixa já vem toda
rebentada é isto parece-me ser coisinhas
para a sanita isto deve Decolar na
sanita e tem um cheirinho bom
oh melhor cheiro que eu já cheirei na
vida cheirar Pois é o cheirinho amar
aqui estão as instruções super
esclarecedoras Não é vamos testar aqui
na Caixa mesmo porque eu não tenho uma
sanita perto Bora 3 2 1 vamos isto deve
ser só assim
né esfregar assim na sanita olha gostei
vamos usar isto no meu cu isto aqui são
o quê teclas para o teclado mais
conhecidas em inglês por Kick Caps eu
deste produto vou gostar porque isto
para editar vídeo dá muito jeito uma
tecla para cada efeito com uma cor
designada
GG parece-me Freddy five Nights at
Freddy e não só um vem dois vem o foxy
rapaziada vem o foxy pois olha o foxy já
tá incrível uh Freddy aqui vem com o
microfone gostei eu gostei que vieram
com duas mãos a mais Caso vocês percam
as mãos tem peças a mais vazia caixa
barata está vazia Malta também como
devem calcular não dá para comprar assim
tanta coisa com 20€ né aqui dentro estão
170 € com esta caixa eu estou curioso
porque tem que ser coisas que valem a
pena temos aqui um
astronauta
isto já vem tudo rebentado que é isto
mano Ah é um projetor é um projetor já
sei é um projetor espera o que é que diz
aqui na caixa astronaut ster Sky
projector Olha aí tem aqui uns botões
atrás vamos ver cabo de power vem um
comando já ligou mas isto não
funciona pois tem um botão de on e off
oh ligou e bem isto deve ser incrível
isto deve ser muito incrível eu não sei
se conseguem ver claro que não porque
tem muito muita luz né Eu estou a
apontar ali para a parede já estou a ver
já estou a ver o espaço incrível Calma
eu vou apagar as luzes
aê Ok tem várias cores azul laranja
outro azul outro laranja vermelho Isto é
incrível vegy slicer 14
peças 14 peças O que é que isto faz
corta vegetais e batatas pois olha aqui
dá para batata dá para cebola dá para
maçã dá para couve tudo Olha aí as peças
todas olha curti curti assim já posso
ralar uma cenoura tem aqui outro
utensílio tem umas lâminas tem mais
lâminas isto aqui deve ser para batata
em palito e batata em cubo eia bem isto
não é nada
seguro jogos mortais do brócoli
obviamente eu não vou testar agora
porque eu não tenho assim tantos
vegetais em
casa temos aqui uma coleira ah esta eu
tinha no meu carrinho isto é uma coleira
de choques isto aqui supostamente é
utilizado para treinar cachorros cães
animais mas obviamente eu não vou
utilizar isto no zuk Isto é para um
desafio eu coloquei isto no carrinho
exatamente mas isto vai dar para fazer
alos desafios isto aqui é só amarrar a
coleira ao pescoço com o choque elétrico
e testar espera eu vou testar o produto
o dispositivo que dá cho está ligado
vamos
testar não
funciona
Ai
bom deu um mini choquinho eu exagerei um
pouco a reação mas Isto deu um mini
choquinho já não deu
mais ok deve ter ficado sem bateria só
tinha Power para um choque Ok funciona
próximo produto já vem aberto também eu
não sei o que é que se passa com as
encomendas da TIM mas vem tudo aberto
uma máquina um dispensador de pasta de
dentes com luz UV que elimina bactérias
da escova e também tem o dispensador da
pasta com panel celar Vamos lá ver isto
deve ser um produto mesmo bizarro pois
olha AB isto vem com mais duas peças Ok
cabo USB vou já de experimentar mano
manual de instruções vem com uma fita
cola para colar na parede faz sentido
eia bem Como é que isto entrar ali
dentro
ah agora abre aqui e mete lá para dentro
já percebi Ok Ok Ok pronto
Opá é mais ou menos
Isto é muito
estranho não sei usar isto mano é um
produto para eu testar mais tarde eu vou
abrir a janela em direção a isto e
depois logo vemos como é que
funciona portable mini printer uma
impressora portátil mais uma vez
mandaram mais um cabo USB de power vamos
testar uh Este é Type C gostei já temos
aqui a aplicação dá para imprimir uma
data de coisas texto banners documentos
notas vou tentar imprimir um
texto imprimiu a palavra like este papel
é térmico a impressora aquece no ponto
onde vocês querem imprimir e sai uma
imagem Ok eu vou tentar imprimir uma
foto do zuki agora tem vários efeitos
aqui tem em Cartoon Art 3D vai ser o
zuki em Cartoon vamos ver se a aplicação
realmente funciona Ok ficou muito Malu o
zuk em Carton ficou muito Malu Mas de
qualquer forma Vamos carregar print a
ver o que acontece já está a imprimir Ok
é rápido é muito
rápido zuki da deep web mano mas
funciona funciona o produto e temos aqui
rolos infinitos próximo produto O que é
que temos aqui um tapete Zito Este é
daqueles tapetes virais do tiktok onde
vocês metem os pés e não molha eu acho
que este não é desses virais eu acho que
este molha assim simplesmente é fofo pá
Aceito Aceito eu não sei se isto é assim
tão caro mas está na caixa misteriosa de
produtos caros próximo produto um
limpador multifuncional eu acho que isto
é daquelas caixas com luz ov onde vocês
colocam aqui eu não sei se é água eu não
sei se é água mas mas isto funciona com
luz o v é só é só colocarmos aqui os
óculos e ele meio que esteriliza os
óculos com luz V mas eu não sei se é
preciso água também água ou ácool
isopropílico um dos dois
éa aí eu preciso de ver livro de
instruções Claro tá bastante explícito
adoro este livrinho de instruções
ajuda-me imenso Naruto Kabuto Toy não
percebo
um
[Música]
bom olha eu gostei do produto só não
tenho aqui alcool isopropílico é pena
senão até testava
Opá mano Isto é um ar condicionado
portátil vocês têm noção mais um cabo
meu Deus eu tenho de arranjar uma gaveta
só para cabos temos aqui um ar
condicionado portátil incrível tem uma
ventuinha tem botões de luz ó aqui diz
para colocarmos água água limpa e até
podemos meter essências ó pá eu não quis
arriscar e meti só um pouco pouquinho de
água eu não sei se vai funcionar
uh funciona mano calma e a ventuinha
como é que eu ligo a ventoinha Oi tem
mais Olha
isso ai o quê Isto vai explodir a
qualquer momento olha mas é bem fresco
resulta resulta Isto é bem fresco mas a
ventuinha não liga porquê a luz
funciona isto também funciona
aparentemente mas agora vale a pena 40 €
para
isto senhorita não sei bem ó senhorita
não talvez com uma essência de
baunilha um cachorro embalado não que é
isto pelo tanto pelo Olha uma carpete
caraças gigante cheira a pneu queimado
mas não importa Malta gostam é fashion
olha até gostei só nesta caixa foram 170
€ o produto mais caro Foi o ar
condicionado Malta digam-me aí se eu fui
enganado se eu fui escamado se se coisas
foram demasiado caras digam Qual foi o
vosso produto Favorito o Carlão gostou
vocês também têm de gostar deixem o like
tá bom